[Music]
i noticed that you enjoyed the top
entrances video i put up before so today
we're taking a look at some more anime
entrances
what better way to make an impact than
with a dynamic entry
and today we'll go through some more of
the best ones both heroic
and villainous let's not waste any more
time and let's get on with the show and
dive in to see some more epic anime
entrances
that you may have missed out on we start
the list off with one of the most
recognizable stock figures in japanese
history
oda nobunaga
[Music]
anything less than a stellar entrance is
unacceptable and sengoku basara did him
justice
it's funny because instead of being an
actual entrance he just stood there
nobunaga stands on top of the mountain
with lightning
and his music suddenly blares that's
when you know that you're dealing with
the
odor nobunaga it's just so much impact
for a guy who's simply standing there
looking menacing he didn't even need to
say a word
nor did he need to jump down and mow
down masamune and team in order to make
a statement
something that we're pretty sure he can
do if we base everything from his
appearance
who knew that you could be so badass and
menacing by just standing and gazing
[Music]
after nobunaga we then have shinra with
one of the best moments in early fire
force
let's just say that shinra and tamaki
didn't have the best of starts
it was a rough introduction for the both
of them so i knew that a moment like
this was coming still i believe that
anime moments come down to execution
and despite seeing a save like this
coming a mile away i still found myself
caught up in the moment when i saw it
it was just perfect but in an ironic way
you have shinra the good guy
coming in like an actual devil to save
the girl that
followed by the guy being calm yet
strong in reassuring darmaki just gives
off legit heartwarming imagery if you
were to ask me
it's tamaki's facial expression
afterwards that completely sells the
scene you can see how she cycles through
them as she looks at her savior
whom she's not really on good terms with
this is probably not fire force's
undisputed best scene
but it has to be in the running for that
title
[Music]
we continue with an isakai because why
not
it's not a heroic one though unless
you're just grateful to this character
for getting the ball rolling on the rem
memes
[Music]
the white whales entrance in re zero
will remain one of my favorite
cliffhangers and entrances in the series
there are many entrances that are just
as good throughout the series like
roswall in the mansion arc or reinhardt
saving everyone but i like this one due
to the sheer
tension that it brings it must be the
atmosphere the eerie silence
and the setup of the whole thing then
subaru's phone rings
and you hear nothing but the ringtone of
doom before it finally appears
flying with the moon behind it it was a
mighty figure whose mere presence seemed
to drain the entire army's willpower it
seemed that the battle
had already been decided but suddenly
you have subaru and rem
starting the assault along with heroic
music that gave me goosebumps thus the
much-awaited battle starts and the
episode just cuts off giving us one of
the biggest cliffhangers in the first
season
given the series and its number of
cliffhangers that's actually saying
[Music]
something
let's continue on with a reasonably
recent villain entrance
how about kenny ackerman in attack on
titan yeah
levi
[Music]
i think kenny's entrance is so good
because it's the culmination of hype
you don't see many characters face levi
head-on with a smile on their face
throughout his debut episode you have
this sense of dread encasing you
this in large part due to his in the
shadow scenes
just who is this mysterious figure that
seems to be so threatening the
build-up's all there
you have the name kenny the ripper
getting thrown around a rather elaborate
urban legend and a short intro to the
backstory
then bang kenny makes his big appearance
outright shooting down two people
and nonchalantly greeting levi leading
to one of the more iconic moments in
this season of attack on titan
where levi screams out the name of the
assailant at the top of his lungs
now that's how you make a villainous
entrance good build up
good sense of tension and a sudden and
impactful entrance
that quickly changes the flow of things
um
up next is the grand entrance of the
world's greatest hero
we finish up the first season of my hero
academia with an entrance
from all might
our protagonists so far have been doing
pretty well for themselves given who
they are in the last few episodes of my
hero academia however they can only do
so much
and as we continue on with the battle
that's been slowly going south for them
who better to save the day
than all might this may very well be the
first time you see all might in full
serious mode
everyone's left staring at him as he
walks down without the signature smile
on his face
it's a rare sight but it only means that
help has arrived
and that all the good guys can finally
rest easy what a better way to cap it
off with his own epic line
when someone like all might says that
it's all fine now you better believe it
and ass kicking is about to commence
in a moment that can also double as one
of the best anime saves
we have ichigo saving rookier in the
climax of the soul society arc now i
think this scene has it all
a gigantic mass of power like nothing
you've ever heard before is about to
make short work of rookier
when you have the hero having completed
his training arc just in time
stepping in take note that this was
before bleach power levels went
completely over the rails and when
characters hyping things up through
words still mattered and you have ichigo
just stepping between rookier and the
giant phoenix like a boss
it's a classic and admittedly cliched
scene but i just can't help but love it
after all these years
and i think that this scene set the pace
for the rest of the episode
and the upcoming decisive battles and to
this day this is still one of my
favorite bleach episodes of all
period
[Music]
[Music]
rick
[Music]
for such a critically acclaimed show
like full metal alchemist you've got to
think that it's bound to have one of the
best entrances in anime
well here you go with roy mustang's
entrance against
lust with al and riza in dire condition
against one of the more troublesome
humongous to deal with who else better
to make the save in the entrance than
roy mustang yep i didn't buy the
statement the roy mustang was dead one
bit
because it was pretty much a setup to
lead to a moment like this
and it was just glorious wounded but not
going down
mustang makes his much-awaited return
and takes on lust in one of the top
highlights of fma brotherhood
i'm not the only one who saw his return
coming right still that knowledge
doesn't make this moment any less epic
as we gifted the scene of mustang being
awesome and just brute forcing his way
through lust's regeneration
with his unmatched firepower no pun
intended regeneration and near
immortality got you down
you're just not using enough firepower
next up make way for the almighty kaido
in this moment from one piece
if you're making a case of being one of
the most overpowered characters you
better make sure to secure the complete
package
an intimidating appearance and a
menacing weapon aren't merely enough
not in a world like one pieces we've
seen it all in one piece
so for your next big villain he has to
go the next step and make an entrance to
remember
and kaido did just that this is but a
preview of things to come
as he'll undoubtedly be one of the
toughest obstacles the straw hats have
to overcome in one piece history
given how long one piece has been going
on that's saying something
[Music]
secretive
among the seven deadly sins who's the
best at flexing
eskanol by far literally or not the big
guy has shown himself to be one of the
strongest among the group
and someone of that stature completely
deserves moments to just show off a bit
and make an impact
i mean he's the sin of pride after all
eskenor gets his chance against esther
rosa of the commandments
it's amazing to see eskenor just
nonchalantly walking towards esther rosa
completely no selling his powers much to
the latter's shock i find it a very
badass moment and at some point
straight up disrespect to the villain
it's a good way to open the curtains for
the fight which is really good in its
own regard so you should find a video of
the fight after watching this
and see the fun for yourself if you
haven't already
[Music]
finishing up our top 10 today is
madara's appearance
[Applause]
for so long in the series you've heard
the name madara he's been spoken of as
this all-powerful legendary figure that
played such a big role in a lot of stuff
that laid the foundation for the world
of naruto you'd imagine what kind of
broken ninja he has to be to lay claim
to all those stories wouldn't it be
crazy if he were to somehow appear in
the great ninja war
how would everyone match up against him
well your questions got answered with a
bang
and not in a good way for the
protagonists similar to kaido
what really made this moment stand out
is the hype beforehand madara has been
built up
really well for so long and when he did
appear he delivered
an army against him no problem the car
gaze against him
no problem the hero team against him no
problem madara really delivered on the
hype and i can't help but think that
kishimoto
actually wrote himself into a corner by
making moderate too strong
making some major plot twists necessary
for the good guys to defeat him
nonetheless madurai stomping the shinobi
alliance for me is not just one of the
most iconic moments in naruto
but shonen anime as a whole
so how about you what are some of the
best entrances that you have in mind
that weren't featured
write it down and i might feature it
next time but before that make sure to
check out my previous top anime
entrances video first that's the end of
this video for now
but if i see that you guys love these
kind of videos i might consider doing
another volume of top anime entrances
in order to show that you liked this
video hit the thumbs up
and click that subscribe and bell button
so you never miss any new uploads
i'll see you next time on video
[Music]
you